In China, Chinese health experts confirmed...
...the new coronavirus that has now killed six people is contagious,...
...raising fears that the virus could spread quickly among people.
Iran has asked the US and France for equipment...
...to download information from black boxes on a downed Ukrainian passenger plane,...
...a request that will add to international frustration...
...at Tehran's failure to send the recorders abroad for analysis.
In Iraq, clashes between Iraqi security forces and anti-government protesters...
...continued at Mohammed al-Qassim highway in central Baghdad.
In Switzerland, US President Donald Trump...
...took center stage at the World Economic Forum in Davos...
...to tout the success of the US economy...
...amid questions about his upcoming impeachment trial.
Finally from the US, Chief House Prosecutor Adam Schiff...
...accused Senate Republican Majority Leader Mitch McConnell...
...of organizing a "rigged" impeachment trial for Donald Trump...
...and working "in concert" with the president.